so far I've got about $200 worth of
parking tickets in
Manhattan because of the unjust Eric
Adams Administration targeting me
because I've been critical of him um but
let's see there this is a great video of
somebody getting pulled over we don't
see enough of these I am because the
woke people are at the end we know this
they know it the people that have been
performatively woke for a very long time
right I mean uh you know all these PE
Schumer is in the IDF now like
everybody's everybody is moving in the
direction of blatant naked
self-interest I've C and but that this
is what's happening I called that uh
years ago all woke is is a patina it's
it's basically going no this is about
everyone else that's all woke is it's
all it is it's actually about everyone
else but it's not it's about you it was
a great way to elevate mediocre people
in the Arts the these overeducated
degree holders from Liberal art schools
that owed a shitload of money in student
loans and had nowhere to work they
bullied their way into these diversity
coordinator [__] positions
sensitivity readers HR departments
inflated with all these things that's
what it was it was always
disguising
self-interest with altruism no it's for
the collective it's for the better but
now it's become a cartoon and we've seen
it and it's actually funny I actually
like them now the people that are still
holding on to this wokeness are actually
becoming fun because they are the ones
that are not too good they're not great
at hiding what they want out of it this
woman who looks whiter than me by the
way is pulled over here in do we know
what country this is this is the United
States yeah so this is the United States
of America and the cops are really on
their best behavior
here the United States of America do we
know what state uh I believe somewhere
in the midwest so in the midwest which
where we're we're told is just it's a
ski shoot where they just kill everyone
these cops yeah somewhere in the midwest
you see this woman being pulled over and
she starts talking and it is so funny
roll this tape what's going on nothing
why are you driving in the wrong way of
traffic no I just got changed around I
just moved here like 2 months ago and
just got changed around okay do you
understand what's going on though you're
going in oncoming traffic I know and I
just decided that it was better just to
turn around really quick okay but I'm
sorry I just have like really bad social
anxiety and stuff stop this for a second
I've driven drunk a lot the nightmare
the Nightmare and I've really I've never
got pulled over I got pulled over High a
few times but it's hard for them to
prove um the nightmare is the first
thing she said I got changed around yeah
HH there's nothing worse than the first
thing you say they know cuz now you know
you're getting the
test you know when you say something
dumb like that it's going to end with
the test there's no like you have a
split second to convince them like
literally when I get pulled over now I'm
like listen I'm not sober I I I go I'm
sober you could look at my Wikipedia I'm
a comedian I know it's late I'm coming
from somewhere else I was going 113
miles hour which I thought was the speed
limit and the reason I'm going uh that
is because I have probably and not to be
you know a dick about it sir but I have
maybe the most impressive sedan in the
country at the moment it seems weird to
drive at 76 miles an hour I'm 36 I
haven't treated my body great I don't
know how long I'll be here so I'm
enjoying the times as we have them and
frankly uh it would be great to get just
you know you know have a Mac truck slam
into me and everything because at the
end of the day it's a real clean way to
make an exit so I'm not sober there's
not much you can get me on you can write
me a speeding ticket I'm sure you will
I'm not going to go that much slower
though it doesn't seem fair uh but this
woman uh again once you say I changed
around it's all over keep going here you
I don't want to step out whenever you're
asking
for stuff okay well we're past that so
just go ahead and step out as an
indigenous
person
right back here please Miss Perry am I
well I'm nonbinary so okay what do you
go by Kai how can I refer to you tonight
K okay hey I'm smelling alcohol I know
how much have you consumed tonight like
probably third J I need to run you
through some tests right now stand
facing me please but I just want you to
know that I also have very bad social
anxiety you and me both like she's at a
party okay okay any recent head trauma
traumatic brain in injuries anything I
need to know about uh mental
yes focus on my finger please I am
you're just like trying to intimidate me
I don't know how I'm trying to do that
this is the test as you know as an
indigenous person and there's a bunch of
going
around I'm sorry but it's just for me to
be on my toes I get you can you remember
that I told you that in
nonbinary yeah I'll try my hardest I'll
refer to you as Kai right yes perfect I
need to know if you have any injuries or
anything that would prevent you from
doing a standard walk or a turn tonight
mental health um any physical
injuries mentally yeah but no I'm just
saying okay ptsc depression anxiety I
get you what else you want now with your
right foot place it in front of your
left in a heel to toe touching manner
with your arms by your side this man you
know what I've noticed this is a new
thing people just say they have PTS now
and no one has to prove where it came
from right like people just say that now
like that was reserved for Veterans of
Foreign
Wars like I understand anxiety and
depression what but people just say I
have post traumatic stress disorder that
when I was growing up and up until
recently was reserved for people who had
been in like a crazy situ like like you
were held at
gunpoint or something and had PTSD
because of that people say they have
PTSD now they don't even trace it to an
event they don't even like talk about
what it somebody should have a killer
story if they have PTSD somebody should
be like I have PTSD and just go really
and they go yeah it was on a cruise it
was the whole Captain Phillips thing
they can't the Somali pirates came on
guns to the Head then you go oh I get it
but somebody people just go I have PTSD
now and don't
specify doesn't it have to be linked to
an event I'm pretty sure it did MH like
if somebody goes I'm from Gaz I have
PTSD I'd go I get it I get it but
someone who's name is like Miss
Perry who's driving drunk through the
cornfields of our Heartland just goes I
have PTSD I mean you know and and and
you know I would ask her if I a cop I'd
go oh that's tough you serve her what is
it from you know keep
going can you not call me man please I'm
trying my hardest okay well okay it
means a lot to me I'm trying my hardest
I don't feel like a man so okay it's
kind of triggering right foot in front
of your left nope go back I'm sorry
about that whole man thing just
like
I going hard zero
questions no but I just want to tell you
that I suffer from really bad anxiety
especially with generational trauma and
ptsc
around white people and yeah pts
generational tra what happened to oring
to suck people off no I mean truly like
what happened to just going like can I
suck your
[__] like instead of it's got to work
more often than this [__] it's got to
work more often than this [__] it's gota
more than generational trauma just go
can I suck your officer can we turn this
camera off can I just go in the back and
suck you off when's the last time you
you've really had a good blow I mean a
good [__] I mean I don't come up
until you're done [__] like I that's
got to work more than this [__]
generational trauma but this is the
problem now we have told women we've
lied to women so much in this country
we've told them to to be girl bosses
instead of rais families and we've also
told them when a cop pulls them over
they shouldn't immediately think about
offering to suck their [__] because that
really is a much better thing I would I
would offer to suck more cops off if I
thought it would help I don't think in
my case it would